we all have our own unique blueprint and
we have something to say and express
that's uniquely ours and there's
something important about everybody
exploring that in themselves and that
doesn't mean they need to quit their
jobs and you know go pick apples to
write a book but I think a sense of full
Integrity with who you are is somewhat
Reliant upon being in communication with
your own you know with your own sense of
who you are and sharing that with the
world because there's only one you right
and you talk about this all the time so
please share it and don't keep it to
yourself because the more you repress
that I think that leads to all sorts of
dysfunction